[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing Harry
Potter Lord Voldemort and Powerful
mother to Draco Narcissa Malfoy
specifically we're going to be taking a
look at her actions following the
alleged death of Harry in the Deathly
Hallows and how One Lie may have changed
the future of the Wizarding World let's
get into it one of the most emotional
and pivotal moments in the Harry Potter
series is the death of the titular
character himself Harry after cheating
death time after time in large part due
to his mother's loving sacrifice Harry
finally faces the afterlife head-on
after meeting Voldemort in the Forbidden
Forest and sacrificing himself he saw
the mouth move in the flash of green
light and everything was gone unlike
Harry's previous confrontations with
Voldemort from his meeting with a
fragmented Voldemort possessing
Professor Quirrell to their duel in the
graveyard of little Angleton this time
Harry did not intend to defend himself
or fight back he came to die and with
Harry's death came a lot of questions
for the reader sure but especially for
the characters in the story after being
hit with Voldemort's killing curse Harry
wakes up in a sort of limbo where he is
met by Dumbledore in this new
environment Harry learned that yes he
has died but he has an opportunity to
come back Harry is given an option to
return to the land of the living because
his mother's sacrifice the same magic
that has protected him for all his life
is still alive in Lord Voldemort's veins
this happens because Voldemort used
Harry's blood when producing his
regeneration potion a potion which
restores a maimed wizard to their true
bodily form further tying Harry to the
land of the living is the fact that
Voldemort's killing curse destroyed the
piece of Voldemort Soul attached to
Harry and not Harry's Soul Dumbledore
confirms this by saying your soul is
whole and completely your own Harry
but while the short period that Harry
was dead may have gone by quickly for
Harry it likely felt like an eternity
for the loved ones that witnessed his
dead body while Harry was discussing
life and death with Dumbledore everyone
else thought that it was the end for our
protagonist this brings us to the moment
in question the scene in which Narcissa
Malfoy inspects Harry's dead body hands
softer than he'd been expecting touched
Harry's face pulled back an eyelid crept
beneath his shirt down to his chest and
felt his heart he could hear the woman's
fast breathing her long hair tickled his
face he knew that she could feel the
steady pounding of Life against his ribs
is Draco alive is he in the castle The
Whisper was barely audible her lips were
an inch from his ear her head bent so
low that her long hair shielded his face
from the onlookers yes he breathed back
he felt the hand on his chest contract
her nails pierced him then it was
withdrawn she had sat up he is dead and
now Sister Malfoy called to the Watchers
and now they shouted now they yelled in
Triumph and stamped their feet and
through his eyelids Harry saw bursts of
red and silver light shoot into the air
in celebration still feigning death on
the ground he understood Narcissa knew
that the only way she would be permitted
to enter Hogwarts and find her son was
as part of the Conquering Army she no
longer cared with a Voldemort one in
this moment we witnessed Narcissa lie to
Voldemort and her fellow Death Eaters a
decision which leads to a crucial
turning point in the series throughout
Harry Potter Narcissa had been portrayed
as a devoted follower of Voldemort and
her husband Lucius was a high-ranking
Death Eater but despite all of this she
decided to turn her back on her allies
and lie next I want to answer two things
why and how the much easier question to
answer and the one I'm going to tackle
first is the why why would she risk
lying to one of the darkest wizards of
all time put succinctly it comes down to
her maternal instincts and her desire to
protect her son Draco she knew that
lying to Voldemort would be the only way
she would be able to return to the
castle to search for Draco she lied in
order to urge a Voldemort back to the
castle fully knowing that he wouldn't be
able to resist the opportunity to flaunt
his success though Narcissa was a
devoted servant of the dark lord her
love for her family would always come
first and like the Voldemort was a risk
that she was willing to take to protect
her son Draco had been used and abused
by Voldemort and was given a nearly
suicidal role in the war as a way of
mocking the malfoys particularly Lucius
who would constantly let him down it's
likely that Narcissa resented Voldemort
for that and when she found out that
Harry was still alive she realized there
was a very good chance that the good
guys would Prevail her confidence in
good prevailing over evil and increased
and she knew that lying was the best
chance that she would have to see her
son before he was potentially killed
killed for his affiliation with the dark
lord narcissus Allied to Voldemort about
Harry Potter being dead in order to
protect her family and gain favor with
the dark lord however in doing so she
indirectly helped Harry and his allies
to defeat Voldemort in the final battle
next I want to discuss the pal the main
reason that I ask how is because
Voldemort is a legitimens a wizard that
has mastered the art of accessing
people's minds and reading their
thoughts provided that Voldemort is one
of the most if not the most impressive
legitimans in The Wizarding World it
stands to reason that lying to Voldemort
would be a futile Endeavor Voldemort
could almost always tell who was lying
to him and even knew what people were
thinking before they uttered a word
there are only a few ways that
narcissors lie could have gotten past
Voldemort the first possible explanation
is that Narcissa is a skilled aquamans a
ritual wizard who is able to effectively
close their mind off to attacks from
legilimons there are many skilled
documents in the Harry Potter series
with Dumbledore and Snape being strong
examples Voldemort wouldn't dare try to
enter the mind of Dumbledore and Snape
was able to deceive Voldemort for
decades all thanks to this ability but
the likelihood that Narcissa was skilled
enough in this particular ability seems
unlikely somehow the next possible way
that Narcissa would have been able to
light a Voldemort relates to his sheer
arrogance despite being a powerful
Mastermind and magical Prodigy we see
Voldemort make little mistakes on a
consistent basis throughout the series
and more often than not I would wager
that these mistakes relate to his
megalomania and his deluded self-belief
that he is so powerful that no one
should ever be able to contest him more
often than not his ego gets in the way
of a success and in this instance he was
probably so elated with the fact that he
defeated Harry and so overconfident in
his powers that he didn't stop to
properly consider whether or not Harry
had truly died another perfect example
of this is that Voldemort truly believed
no one would ever uncover the truth
about or find his horcruxes if Voldemort
had dropped his ego a bit then I think
that the Harry Potter ending would have
been a lot different the last
possibility for bahao Narcissa
effectively lied to Voldemort comes back
once again to the power of maternal love
there seems to be a trend in the Harry
Potter books and films with mothers
protecting their children as well as the
powerful magic that seems to be
generated as a product of this love the
first and best example is Lily Potter
and her sacrificial protection which we
know saved infinihari protected him for
most of his life and temporarily
defeated Voldemort the next best example
is Molly Weasley protecting Ginny from
Bellatrix the strange despite Bellatrix
being one of the most powerful witches
in The Wizarding World Molly was able to
summon the power to defeat her after her
daughter is put in life or death
situation and if you've played or kept
up to date on Hulk Legacy then you'll
know that these are both forms of
ancient magic for a deep dive on Ancient
magic you're going to have to watch my
video history of ancient magic but for
now let me Briefly summarize the term
ancient magic refers to powerful complex
spells and rituals that have been passed
down through Wizarding history for
thousands of years obscure but
incredibly Mighty magic that is shrouded
in mystery and has dissipated over the
course of time in fact by the time Harry
Potter was born ancient magic was
extremely uncommon the only known
examples of this magic in the Wizarding
World stem from eternal love and I'm of
the impression that Narcissa Malfoy may
have also exercised some form of ancient
magic when lying to Voldemort ancient
magic would explain how a powerful
agilemans like Voldemort would have been
tricked so easily by narcissus lie and
it makes perfect sense if we consider
the context and the role that maternal
love plays in Harry Potter in fact JK
Rowling herself has commented on this
segment explaining that this moment was
designed to emphasize the power of
maternal love what do you guys think how
did narcissus lie to Voldemort what
theory checks out to you please leave a
comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live